donc les amis on est on est on a le
retour de niall qui a plus qu'un point
de retard sur sam sevian samse vian
supposé être un petit peu moins forts en
bulles est mais séduit 1 + 1 donc ça va
être très chaud forcément le l'américain
qui débutait la séquence de bullet avec
deux points d'avancé il ya plus qu'un
point d'écart ça va être tendu jusqu'au
bout il doit rester à peu près 27
minutes de jeu et donc on est dans un
nouveau système de londres une nouvelle
fois cette structure de type française
c'est une partie qu'on a on a déjà vu
cette position dans le match et
cavaliers qui vient à eux trois les
blancs qui veulent fixer la case au sein
des cavaliers j'ai quatre cavaliers eux
cinq ils ont retardé le rock pour
pouvoir si jamais reprendre 2 h et
mettre la pression sur le roc adverse ou
b 5 ans déjà parlé plus tôt si on met la
pression sur le cavalier pour gagner
cette case de 5 le fou qui arrivant au 5
mai ça va donner la case f4 fatalement
au cavalier noir mais cette fois ci les
blancs encore le fou de cases blanches
et donc y aura plus les soucis qu'on a
connu en début de match avec le roi
qu'il ne pouvait pas ok cavaliers f5
est-ce que j'ai 4 est jouable ici non il
y aurait cavaliers pros ou trois
intermédiaires ce ne serait pas une
vraie fourchette cavaliers pour
j'imagine plutôt g prend quoi que prend
possible aussi mais après rock à tour
encore plus intéressant savait qu'après
rock il faut garder pour les noirs
l'initiative allait droit sinon ils se
feront lycée j'ai quatre tours prend aux
cavaliers f4 donc il a filé la call of
il a filé la call of
et là peut-être petit rock tout bêtement
camp rock pardon tout bêtement
il n'y a pas de n'y a pas de mauvaises
et coups de me2 mauvais d'échec façon le
fou couvre et les noirs qui vont se
faire repousser petit à petit
éventuellement par du hk tour g1 h5 qui
peut faire mal aux responsables ans par
attention h4 est peut-être dame prend
2,5
tout ça n'est pas si simple il ya aussi
des quatre qui peut traîner il fait tour
d eux un touret fuite
est-ce que h4 scache 4 est une
possibilité peut-être f3 d'abord pour
consolider le pion et fermer la
diagonale du fou et peut-être maintenant
h4 intermédiaire le fou est attaquée
mais on n'a pas créé la dame qui est une
pièce éventuellement évidemment plus
forte que le fou la dame va probablement
repartir de la recette le fou vers
détroit
c'est pas grave de se faire échanger le
fou ici on a un avantage matériel de ce
cavalier 4 est un vrai monstre baies 5
pouces et deux peut-être dû h5 g5 ou g5
direct les noirs en tout cas qu'ils
s'organisent qui attaquent à fond
allèles dame
la tour en 3 la tour en des 8 du coût
actuellement le pion e5 le cavaliere 4
pardon n'est plus en prise la tour qui
vient en et en des huit pour jouer des
quatre tours e1 peut-être des quatre qui
va arriver dame prend h4 le pion h qui
tombe c'est vrai que j'ai pas trop aimé
pour les blancs ce plan-là de partir sur
la colonne je vois pas trop ce qu'on
fait niall sarine qui a perdu le fil de
la partie le fils il va falloir le
retrouver parce que lui samuel sevian le
fil
il a peut-être d'un match de tours h1
des coups simples dames e3 qui attaque
peut-être tout rachat d'amd de il
revient damage de tours h1 et peut-être
pas une idée ce cavalier f4 est vraiment
monstrueux
la dame qui parent bessette c'est plutôt
le roi blanc qui se fait attaquer ça le
sévillan qui est vraiment vraiment chaud
mais il donne la casse des quatre à
présent peut-être faut-il rentrer dans
la finale puis on prend peut-être four
b3 dam des quatre îles joutes damas est
trop il joue pour tours à huit dames à
un match c'est le beau jeu c'est le beau
jeu et surtout b 3 pions c4 puis on
prend ces cinq tours à huit qui va
arriver foulée trois des quatre en
premier alors attention il veut quoi il
veut du fou prend f3 est fou et 4 pour
complètement enlevé au ces jolies le fou
qui revient au g4 qui va venir au f5 et
qui va complètement bloqué le roi dans
le corner fouet f5 échec et tour à 8 me
paraît fort mais il a commencé par g5
pour une raison qui m'échappe le roi
blanc qui va pouvoir partir vers ces
deux dames à 5 attention ces six
monneret plomb c'est qu'ils parlent fou
échec roi c1 dames un roi des deux était
à matam des deux rois de trois cavaliers
g2 je sais pas sa part de partout autour
des 8 il prend le roi contre pied il
prend la tour qui revient en des 8es
yade à main maths qui menace c'est ce
que yahoo croient aussi ces chèques
peut-être non y avait été défendue du
coup il a rendu la dame la dame qui va
pouvoir revenir vers à 5 éventuellement
aux cavaliers de m'attendre victoire de
sa viande qui reprend deux points
d'écart 4,5 du coup de nouveau les
blancs on va jeter un oeil sur le
chronomètre il as encore 22 minutes de
jeu au f5 je crois bien que c'est le
gambit janish le gambit janish qui est
envoyé par nial sarine ya le sarine qui
a de nouveau deux points de retard mais
qui n'a vraiment pas bien maîtrisé la
partie précédente ils avaient l'avantagé
la paix
du le fil cavaliers pro 5 petit roquet
c3a les savants chez nous on va mettre
une amende que en d6 le fou qui va
peut-être venir angers 4 niall qui doit
absolument recoller au score sous peine
d'avoir un retard beaucoup trop grand
fou b6
on va voir est ce qui va prendre le fou
en b 6 il a le temps le fou de toute
façon sous pression lecavalier a eu cinq
menace est tout de même en y prend puis
on prend qu'elle prend celle ci prend
les pions il ya depuis leucate qui va
tomber ce qu'il va y avoir de la tacc
pour les noirs je n'ai pas l'impression
les blancs qui pourront blindes
éventuellement par f3 le fou qui sera
éteint danev 3 proposait change des
dames est ce qu'on peut aller prendre en
d4 et jouait sur un truc complètement
fou avec du cavalier cap non il le fait
pas il échange les dames mais si on
compte les pions c'est à la fin du
village qu'on compte les maisons les
amis et la fin du village le village
blanc une maison de maisons trois
maisons quatre maisons cinq maisons six
maisons côté noir on n'a que cinq
maisons il ya une maison de retard est
ce que les noirs vont pouvoir
reconstruire des maisons voire même
avoir un permis de destruction sur les
maison blanche
c'est à voir est ce que la mairie
donnera les autorisations c'est une
question en cours pour le moment côté
indien donc ni al sarine qui peut quand
même compter sur les fous de couleurs
opposées pour résister le pion à 3 peut
être un petit peu sous pression
attention tour d un pour chasser le fou
éventuellement des découvertes
si lecavalier en vient à bouger il y
aurait du pousser deux c'est pour ça
qu'ils jouent ces 5 mai fouet f4
intermédiaire tout reprend des trois
pions prend des 4 enfin puis on prend
des quatre tours prend des 3 puis on
prend ces trois tons pensée 3 et option
des sinistrés seraient en difficulté
niall sarine qui semble en difficulté
effectivement mais il a un peu plus de
temps cependant la position est assez
simple à jouer ici mais il rajoute du
bordel au bordel cavaliers des cinq sur
le tour prend des trois éleveurs caprins
f4 mais fou prend des six est la
question
il prend maintenant une fois et va
prendre du cavalier avec l'idée que
surtout on prend des quatre cavaliers eu
deux échecs la petite pointe du joueur
indien qui essayent de s'en sortir
élégamment mayroy f1 on empêche tous les
problèmes et maintenant ton pions des 4
et toujours en prise à mon avis le
joueur américain ici a un avantage
certain
cav a lieu quatre tours prend des quatre
il n'y a pas de piège le gambit janish a
pas fonctionné mais il va essayer de
jouer tour ces deux pour s'activer
fond sur la deuxième rangée le joueur
blanc qui réussit à remettre son fou en
2 1 pour défendre le plomb f2 et
colmater la seconde rangée mais pour le
moment ça tient tout est protégé le pion
à troyes le pion f2 à cavaliers pros f2
à le à denis brogniart qui a été lâchée
et du coup la tour qui arrive en f2 mais
les blancs qui colmate par tour g4
encore et qu'ils vont réussir à se
consolider alors maintenant est ce qu'on
va voir un g6 côté noir ou h6 pour jouer
g5 éventuellement pour ces deux rois h7
mais les plans qui vont jouer pour
tourner un tour 17 peut-être tour à tour
g3 qui défend le pion et les blancs qui
vont réussir à s'activer la tour en g3
c'est une pièce ses positions vraiment
préférentiels pour cette tour pourquoi
parce qu'elle défend g2 et l attaque g7
donc elle fait de boulot c'est du deux
en un c'est le shampoing 3 en 1 presse
et maintenant on va être obligé avec les
noirs de défendre une finale avec une
tour une tour un pion de loin et elle
est dure à jouer c'est du bullet et
c'est pas une balle de match bien
évidemment mais c'est une vraie balle de
break ont mènerait on pourrait dire de
7,0 côté côté sévillan qui montrent le
roi après avec le pion la tour derrière
ça peut faire nul mais il va falloir
faire un numéro d'équilibriste côté
indien pour la tenir sévit en plus qui a
déjà montré à plusieurs reprises qu'il
était vraiment bon temps avec peu de
temps sur la pendule le roi à qui mon
temps j'ai cinq tours b3 qui va être
forcé mais à tout reproche et sissach on
apprend à 5 tours angers 63.5 et ça va
faire plus trois pour le joueur
américain je vous l'annonçais c'est
complètement gagnant c'est assez simple
à gagner après c'est normal de côté nyan
win de la joue encore un peu mais non on
voit la déception nada sur son visage
une petite grimace qui a été lâché et ça
continue qu'à l'épreuve de était jolie
mais le joueur américain qui a très vite
réagi en mettant la tour sur la colonne
g et c'est ça qui a fait la différence
maintenant on a un genre de système
stonewall avec les blancs avec le fou
qui a réussi à passer angers 5 en
premier c'est hyper hyper hyper
important là pour l'indien de marquer il
n'y a plus le choix maintenant il n'y a
plus le choix alors est ce qu'on peut un
cavalier e 5 essayer de mettre une dame
en h5
pas si sûr graf 6 peut-être on laisse le
fou en prison n'a pas qu'à fond même si
j'imagine du damage 5 à la barbare à la
dure allez y prend on peut reprendre
même de f issifou pranger 5 qui ont
prolongé cinq dames pranger 5 on aurait
fou prend âge cet échec méprendre 2d
aussi intéressant pour bien amener les
pions à l'est le roi est mené l'attaqué
à la sarine qui réfléchit il a un petit
peu changé de braquet y jouer très vite
dans les parties précédentes mais
maintenant il prend le temps de jouer et
on a des prend 1,5 donc il veut vraiment
vraiment vraiment amener tous les pions
vers l'est le roi f5 y est joué et
souvent dangereux position en tout comme
g4 intéressant pour venir s'en prendre à
ce pion f5 puis reprise en passant est
aussi intéressante
après le petit défaut ses compères la
mainmise qu'on avait sur la case m6 met
cependant le cavalier va revenir vers la
case eux cinq ils y arrivent d'ailleurs
justement food et 6 pour le chasser et
les blancs qui me paraissent un petit
peu dans le dur
un petit peu dans le dur parce que le la
case des 5
il est papa est pas possible de la de la
conserver et maintenant les noirs qui
peuvent installer leurs cavaliers sur
quatre est complètement coupée cette
attaque blanche
je dirais inial sarine qui veut jouer le
tout pour le tout mais qui va peut-être
pas au bout de ses convictions et
maintenant le fou est enfermé alors
est-ce que c'est grave non parce que
damages 5 et sur fion prend on pourra
jouer fou j'ai six ou plus on prend et à
les mater à la dure des cas être
maintenant et il faut y aller faut aller
jusqu'au bout de ses convictions résiste
prouve que tu existes peut-être fou
prend 1,6 puis on prend et roy g1 et
tant pis si on voit jamais sur puis on
prend il aura pu comprendre la lame
intervient en défense non je dis
n'importe quoi donc j'ai 3 eyes fait des
trois os et bien jouer des trois assez
bien bien joué il coupe complètement les
ailes des blancs et là il va y avoir du
pion pranger 5 kg on prend et foin f4 au
ca fait mal
trois jets d'oeufs et fou pranger 5
élimine le pion g6 qui pouvait fermer la
porte et alors là maintenant attaque moi
si tu peux
alors là encore une petite petite
combine sur damev cette tour prend h6 il
va falloir vérifier qu'on se fasse pas
maté côté blanc dans tous les cas la
finale serait très bien pour les noirs
attention tout de même ce evian qui
prend le temps voilà c'est ce qu'il a vu
mais il va faire juste d'apprendre ici
s'il va rentrer dans la finale je vous
parlais de cette finale il ya juste
quelques secondes et cette finale elle
est complètement gagnante nihal sarine
qui n'y peut rien le pion détroit est
vraiment fort tour f1 très bien joué on
échange ta tour passive mais on pousse
des dos d un sévillan qui s'envolent +4
à la surprise générale c'est le joueur
américain
tel un boa constrictor qui aura
construit qui aura tueur a construit ce
match depuis les cinq plus un ce match
en cinq sets
et petit à petit l'étreinte qui ce qui
s'enroule autour du cou de l'indien un
coût qui du coup est complètement con
qu'on construisait par par le bo
américain le bois américain qu'il a dans
système de londres a pas du tout réussi
à mettre la pression
il va à jouer à une position plus ou
moins égales mais il reste plus que 15
minutes de jeu est-ce que ça le gêne de
faire une nulle en trois minutes ici non
ce serait une bonne opération pour le
joueur américain qui forcerait à aniane
sarine à faire la différence avec les
blancs mais malheureusement il aura pas
quatre parties avec les blancs donc il
faut absolument marquer côté noire
fournie à la sarine alors ils échangent
tout ça ait changé stratégie
intéressante c'est vianne vraiment qui
est aujourd'hui vraiment très lucide il
connaît le score il comprend la
dynamique du match il doit regarder les
speechs s est hissée qu'une nul dans ce
à ce moment du match est en sa faveur il
joue le système de londres il laisse la
variante avec des 5
il va là yves il fait il fait le truc
qu'il faut et maintenant ils en
profitent et il va pouvoir laisser
tourner la pendule
on pourra pas dire que ce n'est pas
fair-play parce que cette position là
elle se joue c'est pas une position où
on dit il faut faire nul obligatoirement
c'est une position qu'on peut jouer et
il va laisser tourner le chrono c'est
bien joué c'est bien joué
stratégiquement il faut féliciter le
joueur américain pour un choix
pragmatique
si intéressant plein de bon sens il à
peine 18 ans mais il est déjà plein
d'expériences et de bons choix attention
tout de même de pas se prendre un pion
passé à et crée le pion pas cessé c'est
bien joué
il se crée le pion pas cessé ils
laissent pas ce petit avantage du pion
pas s'éloigner et donc le joueur
américain qui a qui peut plus jouer les
finales de deux pions puisque le pion à
5 et pas s'éloigner alors est ce qu'il
va pouvoir jouer avec ses 5 c'est bien
joué là ce que fait niall sarine c'est
bien joué mais en fait ça fait pas grand
chose parce que ces quatre baies 5 est à
peu près équivalent à 7 à 7 v6 donc la
position est juste complètement nul est
ce que le joueur américain va faire nul
ou est-ce qui va à jouer la montre ça va
être un petit peu la question de cette
femme partie proposition 2 nuls
de la part de niall sarine refusé parce
evian alors est ce qui va basculer du
côté sombre de la force du côté gris
tchouk où tu joues pendant des plombes
pour faire la pendule simplement pour
faire tourner la pendule ou est ce que
maintenant que la position est vraiment
égalé qui a plus de chances de gain pour
les deux il va rester quelque part faire
enfin j'ai envie de dire le statu quo
non on va pas dire le le statu quo mais
je veux dire juste juste faire là nul au
moment opportun
ou est-ce qu'il va jouer jusqu'au bout
moi je le vois bien continuer il est
parti là dedans alors on n'aime pas trop
ça ici bien évidemment mais c'est le jeu
hein qu'est ce que vous voulez signal
sarine voulait éviter ça il avait qu'à
voir quatre points d'avance là les
quatre points d'avance son côté
américain et l'américain qui utilisent
les règles en sa faveur
est-ce qu'on peut le critiquer pour ça
je ne crois pas les amis je ne crois pas
alors le roi g6 dame c63 g7 et c'est
comme ça il fait ces cinq alors il donne
l'illusion de jouer pour gagner mais en
réalité c'est complètement nul
mais il ira y réussit à faire tourner il
fait tourner la pendule fait tourner
tourner tourner tourner et maintenant le
joueur amiens qui va un petit peu qui
n'y peut rien qu'il y peut rien ce
prévenu puissant vous la thèse c'est le
problème du fait d'être en retard dans
le match alors c'est pas si clair à mon
avis encore dans le sens où le joueur
indien réussi à se créer des chances ou
pas il y aura toujours un père pète de
toute façon mais c'est lyon qui joue
quand même le jeu un cerf qui fait nul
salle mais pas trop sale non plus certes
il ya du contre jeu ça joue la partie
continue le pion bva avancer donc là ce
qui fait c'est qu'il veut envoyer un
pion mais le truc c'est que
c'est plutôt les blancs en finale des
dames des cinq damage 5b 4ème et il va
il va avoir mangé combien de minutes
avec ça il va avoir mangé presque 5
minutes et c'est même pas sûr qu'ils la
gagnent pas il va prendre la nulle
maintenant ou pas et même pas il met la
pression maintenant il est même mieux
ouais c'est bien joué assez bien joué et
la dame g3 contre échec et il va gagner
parce que et chaque échec échange de
dames et ça gagne avec le pion j'ai
assez roublard de la part de ces vian
qu'elle roublard échange des dames et
saga orignal sarine écoeuré écoeuré
salle sévillan là qui a fait un job
incroyable avec cette partie il a laissé
tourner quatre minutes trente de pendule
et il a quand même marqué le point et
c'est la partie qui décide du match les
amis ils gagnent là dessus mais vraiment
plein d'expérience peut-on critiquer
sevian pour avoir joué comme ça
honnêtement je ne le pense pas parce que
si vous commencez à critiquer sevian
pour jouer comme ça vous ne regardez
plus une compétition vous ne regardez
plus une compétition c'est à dire que
c'est comme au foot vous mener 1-0 et
vous regardez plus parce que les mecs
qui aiment leur but
au rugby vous menez de 2,8 points ou 2 5
points à la fin du match et vous faites
des petits pick and go vous garder le
ballon et vous faites du cache ballon à
la monster du coup on regarde plus rien
sevian qu'il a joué à l'expérience et
qui s'est même payé le luxe de la sphère
pas trop sale c'est à dire qu'il a quand
même gagné la partie dont type qui peut
s'asseoir à la table de ses vian et lui
dire tu as pas été fair play non il a
joué la règle à fond et il n'a pas
dépassé il n'a pas fait la grille tchouk
il n'a pas dépassé les limites du fair
play du correct il est resté à la limite
il a fait les choses comme il fallait
comme un grand et ça vraiment les amis
c'est à souligner on peut pas critiquer
un joueur pour faire ça au contraire je
pense qu'il faut le féliciter pour sa il
utilise son avantage il utilise c'est
lui qui a pris les quatre points
d'avance c'est normal qu'il ait le
crédit pour ça il a forcé son adversaire
à forcer le gain il a obligé sarine a
joué le gain à fond il était là en
compte
il a contré il a fini proprement c'est
vraiment du travail d'orfèvre ce qu'a
fait c'est bien c'est à ce moment là du
match est vraiment très solide vraiment
bien joué voilà je suis content d'avoir
d'avoir vécu ce moment là parce qu'on a
vu on a vu un beau match le match n'est
pas fini mais mathématiquement c'est que
c'est c'est fini à 1 on a vu un beau
match et on a vu vraiment une
réalisation mieux que chez les adultes
quelque part et ouais c'est comme quand
tu as un gros stack au poker avant la
bulle que tu mets la pression c'est
c'est normal d'avoir c'est comme au tour
de france quand tu as deux minutes
d'avancé que le maillot jaune ils
attaquent pas et qui reste dans le
peloton et que ya le peloton des favoris
et qui a plus de dix mecs et qu'en fait
ils te tiennent ils te font la technique
de la sky et que et qu'ils attaquent
janet même s'ils sont plus forts ils te
laissent épuisé et il te rases aux
poteaux c'est tout avec à être devant
donc ce qu'il a fait c'est tout à fait
correct est donc maintenant il reste le
combiné la ja il n'y avait pas d'âme
ananda main ça marchait pas et mesdames
f1 toujours est donc maintenant il reste
combien il reste 7 minutes 52 matchs bas
il y aura liora y aura pas il y aura
rien les mecs parce que la même mais
même s'ils gagnent de toute façon il ya
encore vingt secondes de pendule à
tourner donc au moins il va encore jouer
une trentaine de coups et ils font au
moins encore une minute mais alors au
super bas mot pour gagner ça et en plus
c'est les noirs qui sont gagnants parce
qu'ils ont un peu un pion de plus par
gagnon non les noirs sont pas du tout
gagnant c'est les noirs ils sont pas
mieux en fait mais on va dire que les
blancs sont pas bien ne font pas mieux
du tout je vois pas pourquoi les blancs
devraient être mieux ici malgré
l'activité il ya quand même ce pion à
reprendre et dans tous les cas même même
si la gagne il va falloir du temps -
ipres quand même c'est plus agréable à
jouer pour les blancs mais
mais bon c'est très très dur et très
long a gagné quand bien même il y
arriverait en plus la même mentalement
c'est compliqué la tour qui revient en
d1 il va réussir à faire tour un prénom
ça va tout à fait pour les noirs et est
en plus mais comme je disais il est on
est la pendule hires quoi il reste 6
minutes 50
il n'y a pas de match il va récupérer de
pionsat va s'échanger et là je dirais
que mathématiquement il est la victoire
est déjà assurée à 99,99 pour cent je
donnerai une cote de 10 mille contre 1
pour fournir le sarine je prendrai quand
même c'est bien messi gagne cette partie
là ou s'il fait nul
il y aura même plus de côtes ce sera ce
sera du zéro contre un ce sera fini ce
sera cote aaa serait une cote à
d'ailleurs sarine qui comprend sur la
caméra qu le match est perdu il reste il
reste six minutes 20 elles n'ont de
toute façon la plus simple c'est
absolument impossible
dans tous les cas ce sera une victoire
et la fausse info pranger 3 dans ce
match pour sévillans qui vend plus se
payer le luxe d'arriver à +6 à la fin de
cette partie il ya absolument rien à
faire il va même se faire y'avait pas f6
matt hahn en effet f6 maths parce que le
roi était cloué mais là ils pouvaient
plus éviter fouet furtur f5 maths qui
menaçait sur gk tff quatre matches et ça
fait plus 6 et ouais et c'est gagné et
le match est gagné
bravo bravo samuel c'est bien plus beau
match de la saison les joueurs ont été
solides on n'a pas vraiment il était
plus fort dans tout les cadences et il a
vraiment construit sa victoire peut-être
pas plus forts de base en bullet un plus
un mais il a
ça ça a payé il a mis la pression tout
le match il était un peu plus fort dans
les moments chauds il a été il est un
peu plus fort dans tous les
compartiments du jeu et cette pression
qui s'est construite depuis les premiers
instants du match qui a fini par par
faire la différence